jason witten unretiring after one year
in the monday night football booth for
espn he is back with the dallas cowboys
we were interviewing pete carroll
yesterday when i made the mistake of
looking at my phone and seeing that and
i thought it was fake i thought somebody
had been hacked there's no way jason
went after a four-year-old it's one
thing to say that jason witten was
considering coming back during the 2018
season which apparently was a thing but
the fact that after a full season out of
football he would come back
and play
it's an escape hatch from the monday
night football booth but
you're not exactly escaping to something
good you're in your late 30s and you're
going to be playing football again yeah
after one full year out of it what was
your reaction when we heard the news
i was with you i was shocked i really
thought you were joking when you first
said it out loud i did not believe that
um at the same time once i knew that it
was real news hey i mean
i think he flirted with this a little
bit last year i think the reports that
we heard that the dallas cowboys had
reached out and would have loved to have
uh had him back on the roster i think
all of that was real and obviously for
to get out a little bit he probably
entertained the thought as well but we
talked a little yesterday he looks like
he has stayed in shape um so yeah i mean
hey he's going back to do something he
loves and i think the the fascinating
thing that just looks at it is these the
snaps per game they've kind of agreed on
and i know that's a tentative thing so
bizarre it is very bizarre 25 snaps a
game how in the world do you monitor
that i know and if he gets to 25 snaps
in the third quarter like do you just
take him off the field and say all right
go take a shower you're done exactly
right or do you become too predictable
within those 25 snaps you go jason
witten's on the field you know they're
going to throw the football because they
might not want to waste the 25 snaps on
him you know run blocking which he is
still he was still very good at that at
the end of his career uh but i think at
the end of the day i guess the biggest
thing i wonder was did he have a feeling
that he was going to be pushed out the
door at espn and just kind of you know
jumped jump ship right away to go okay
the hell with dealing with all that
scrutiny i'm just going to go play
football one more year and if he still
loves the sport and has a burning desire
to do it then i'm never mad at anybody
doing that and the only thing i would
say off of that is then why did you
retire in the first place if you still
felt like that was it more he retired
mike you think because he just said oh
i'm coming to the end and there's this
great job available let me just take it
and start my second phase uh or was he
truly sick of football last year and now
he's you know refound the desire
those are things i'd like to ask him
remember last year as he did
abruptly retire from football and it was
news to the cowboys that's news to me
yeah it was news to the cowboys that he
was considering this option and they
tried to downplay it at the time they
didn't want him to retire and i think
that when that window is open for a
network job for one of the prime time
games or one of the spots that that
won't be available next year hey i'd
like to wait one more year well next
year we're going to have somebody in
that job right that is the thing that
can draw you away from it so maybe he
did feel a little compulsion to walk
away into a job that was available that
otherwise wouldn't have been available a
year later right but now that and i
agree with you maybe there was a little
nudge maybe there was a little
suggestion maybe he got the sense it
wasn't working on monday night football
and it's time for him to look for a way
out this is the best way out you escape
back to the thing that you did for all
those years and then you play football
for one year two years who knows how
long this will last it can't last very
long it can't no i would think it's a
one-year thing or maybe it ends up being
another one-year deal right after this
if he feels like okay i got through the
2019 year kind of unscathed i feel
healthy i think i can do it one more
time you know and i think the big thing
is with players that like jason winton
who's going to be a hall of fame tight
end too you know part of playing
football is do they have or when they
get into this part of their career do
they have just the you know what do i
want to say the intensity in the
off-season to continue to work to put
yourself in the best position to play
during the season and do you uh you know
have the intensity to go to training
camp and do those things it's the
playing the games part is easy for guys
like jason whitten and some of the stars
that we see here you know waffling
should i retire should i not it's all
the other stuff i think that wears them
out and i don't know how you feel but i
feel like it is a win-win situation for
both i mean we heard and i know you
heard the same thing that you know
dallas lacks a little leadership within
their locker room and i think that's the
other thing that's really the big point
here is dallas got a guy that they feel
is a calm steady voice within the locker
room to keep everybody on track right
mike and i think
that's another big part he's back on the
roster you've got jason garrett the
coach the team whose back is against the
wall stephen jones the cowboys co said
as much earlier this week last year for
jason garrett of his contract and jason
witten comes back to try to help him
save his job and get that new contract
and maybe propel the cowboys deeper than
they've been since 1995. since 1995 the
last year they won a super bowl they
haven't even played in an nfc
championship game it's amazing it is to
think and they got within one game of it
this past year they made it to the round
of eight they made it to la they lost to
the cow uh to the rams in the coliseum
and fourteen they gave them
they want to get back to the nfc
championship game and and ultimately
jason garrett wants to save his job and
jason wooden has a chance to come back
and and and
look again i don't want to overstate but
i don't want to understate the fact that
it wasn't working for him at espn
everyone knew it and he's sufficiently
self-aware to know it and this was a way
for him
to as gracefully as possible step away
that's we were talking about this last
night the idea that
his
contract was reported as being worth
five million for one year yeah dallas
and that's a trumped-up number that
isn't really the real number but it's
more than what he's making at espn so
it's like wow it's a no-brainer yes
ben's paying for the propaganda
yeah right it's a no-brainer to go take
this job and the reality is there
probably was some so subtle nudging not
that they even had to nudge him he had
to know that this was that this was
something that was heading in not a good
direction for him and i thought that
what they would do
would be put booger mcfarland in the
booth this year have a three-man booth
and after after 2019 it would be you
later jason whitton and it would be joe
tessitore and bo and booger mcfarland
going forward now i don't know what
they're going to do with the espn booth
there are people suggesting they'll be a
different play-by-play person i don't
understand how that would be right like
you just find a new analyst or you just
go with two people but i think whitton
leaving doesn't justify a complete
overhaul of the booth yeah i don't
understand that either i mean it is
going to be interesting does espn going
to make a big play for peyton manning
right i mean those are the names you
think of right away is is peyton manning
willing to get into that situation well
and he's been doing the espn plus videos
with the breakdown
right where he he puts his little
spotlight and and talks football and x's
and o's and breaks down players which is
very cool uh but i had always heard one
of the things too just pertaining to
peyton manning he didn't he doesn't want
to get into this side of the business
especially why his brother's playing eli
manning and maybe some of the other
quarterbacks like tom brady that he's
had a plate again so he doesn't want to
sound like he when he is critical of a
mistake that he's a hater or anything
like that so i understand where peyton
manning's coming from that um i think
the big thing that i i just you know
when i think about this too just going
back to whitten and his uh the
leadership role you know i had people
like kind of text me like leadership
role what is that and you know that is a
real thing with an nfl team you know a
guy that can talk sense into players
especially players and you know this
it's a militaristic approach in the nfl
and a team and what you have to do and
taking orders and being respectful to
your coaches and uh guys like that in
the locker room can be uh you know the
older wise wisdom type of guys and the
other it's like having a sergeant right
it's like having this the coach is the
officer and having an older player who
acts as a leader within the troops
that's got that's the sergeant who tells
and holds the other players against
holds them accountable and then oh it's
it's after practice right and
everybody's walking on the field oh
there's jason witten he's he's doing
drill still and he's working with the
tight ends on blocking techniques and
all of a sudden the defensive tackles
look over and go damn the hall of fame
jason wooden's still out here maybe i
should stay out here and do a few little
extra minutes of work and things like
that that's what a guy like jason
whitton can bring to a team in a
franchise when you hear the leadership
role it just is going to show everybody
a little bit you know hey this is what a
professional does uh to be a jason went
and be a hall of fame type of tight end
and you know when we think about the
other guys that they have right now
you've got ezekiel ali you've got amari
cooper yeah but you know i know they had
dez bryant for much of the last decade
but dez bryant isn't a guy that's going
to stretch the field he isn't a guy
that's going to open things up
underneath right amari cooper can open
things up underneath and make it easier
for jason witten we see antonio gates
still going strong in his late 30s right
you don't have to be
a guy who can who can
outrun linebackers you just have to find
the holes in the zone you know your
system you get open you catch a couple
of passes a game on third down or in the
red zone ideally and that's how you
contribute beyond the leadership beyond
the day-to-day things that happen behind
the scenes that help keep other players
accountable yeah exactly right and and
to your point like i think you're
antonio gates point and you know his
ability to run yeah i mean it's right on
he's not going to be breaking 70 yard
touchdowns or anything like that but
when it's third and four or third and
five you know whether it's man or zone
he's crafty enough and still can move
well enough and he has a big body and
understands how to shield defenders off
to where okay it's third in four he's
gonna get open at the five yard mark and
dak prescott's gonna throw the ball on
his chest and he might be tightly
covered but he's gonna catch it and it's
gonna be first down it's gonna move the
chains and there's a lot of
effectiveness
to that style of play and i do think it
fits within what dallas wants to do the
fire inside of me to compete and play
this game is just burning too strong
witten said in a statement issued
yesterday this team has a great group of
rising young stars and i want to help
them make a run at the championship this
was completely my decision sure it was
and i am very comfortable with it i'm
looking forward to getting back in the
dirt someone needs to tell them they
don't play on it
you're right
i mean i guess well you got philadelphia
they're still playing on grass out there
and they're red skinned
oh it's definitely dirt at fedex field
it's all dirt they paint it green you
know and it's a shame the one thing i
think of
not not that it's a shame i understand
why they did it
the rule that when the guy's helmet
comes off the play ends because that one
play that i'll always remember for jason
whitten the game against the eagles i
think it was a sunday night game the
helmet comes off he kept running
yeah they changed the rule after that
where if your helmet comes off and the
ball carry the play instantly is dead
but that's that's jason witten it is and
it's good that he's back and and we'll
see what they can do and it's just the
cowboys the cowboys are good for
football whether you love them or you
hate them they're good for football and
they don't have a first round pick this
year they can't make a lot of buzz they
have to take care of their own guys it's
not like they go out and sign some big
name free agent something they can do
that creates things for us to talk about
is getting jason witten to unretire even
if he was in the midst of being
subtly nudged out of the booth by espn
so i i like it it was it really was one
of those
oh crap type of moments yeah it was it
definitely was
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports